welcome to the daily climate show stay
with us coming up every heatwave
experienced today is more intense and
more likely because of climate change
we'll hear from one of the scientists
behind that new finding
the un
secretary general declares that the
world is in the middle of an ocean
emergency and calls for nations to act
together to turn the tide
how the area surrounding paris's notre
dame cathedral is being redesigned to
mitigate the effects of climate change
and from recyclable strawberry punnets
to ditching single-use plastic from your
pims why this year's wimbledon is
looking to be the greenest championships
yet
[Music]
welcome to the daily climate show where
we track the changes happening to our
planet hear from those hit hardest by
those changes and report on the race
force solutions
now every heatwave we experience is now
more intense and more likely to happen
because of climate change that's
according to scientists who've reviewed
extreme weather hazards and found
unequivocal evidence that heat waves are
worsening because of global warming the
research also warns that the number of
lives lost and the financial costs of
the changes are being underestimated
the report found heat waves are now
hotter and occurring far more frequently
with the role of climate change
unequivocal average and extreme heat
levels in every continent are increasing
specifically because of human caused
climate change
heavy rain events have become more
frequent and intense across most parts
of the world mainly due to climate
change with a growing number of floods
made more intense by the effects of
rising temperatures on rainfall
but the connection with climate change
is more nuanced in the case of heat
waves wildfire risks have already
substantially increased in many regions
recent blazes seen in places including
canada the united states and australia
have been made much more likely by
climate change causing deaths air
pollution billions of pounds of damage
and of course harm to wildlife
well a little earlier i spoke to one of
the reports authors
professor frederica otto from the
grantham institute for climate change
and environment at imperial college
london i began by asking her how they
reached their conclusions
so what we did in this in this review
paper is that we
we started at the um at last year's ipcc
report and then looked at basically a
decade of
research on
all sorts of extreme weather events
across the world and the role of climate
change in these events and looked at
what are the global conclusions that we
can draw and one of the key conclusions
is that every heatwave that is happening
today has been made more likely and more
intense because of human-induced climate
change
and where are those figures coming from
tell us a bit more about the data and
what you extrapolated
so we haven't looked at
data at measured data but we have looked
at
um at a large
range of published
reports and published academic papers
that have all used
observational data from weather stations
all sorts of other different
observational data products and
many different climate models and all
these papers come to the same conclusion
uh when it is concerned heat waves not
only that climate change does play a
role and makes them more likely more
intense but actually a lot more likely
climate change is a real game changer
when it comes to extreme heat
and you found when it comes to drought
that it's less clear-cut why is that
basically the relationship between
climate change and drought is is much
more complex than than with heat because
um depending on where in the region you
are uh what makes a drought is is quite
different so in regions where for
example it's already uh semi-arid so for
example eastern africa when you have you
have we have an increase in temperature
but that actually doesn't play a big
role for making the droughts worse
because
it has already been always so that
whenever there was rain it evaporated
quickly so there would only be a change
in drought if climate change would make
the rain less and that is for example in
eastern africa not or only to a very
small degree the case but in other parts
of the world like southern africa or the
mediterranean that is the case and so
there climate change does
increase drought risk
and you also warn that the financial
cost and sadly the number of lives being
lost due to climate change are being
underestimated explain just how
dangerous that is and also what can be
done to rectify that
yeah so first of all the reason for that
is that
as i said climate change
is really really
a game changer in heat extremes but in
many parts of the world we actually do
not record heat extremes and so that
means we don't record the death
associated with this even though we know
from the parts of the world where we do
have data that heat waves are the most
deadliest extreme events and we also
don't really comprehensively record the
economic costs and that means that when
we are thinking about how to adapt to
climate change we might ignore the most
obvious and most most dangerous changes
if we don't record heat impacts and heat
extremes
dr frederica otto thank you so much for
coming on the show and explaining that
research
thank you
let's get some more of the day's climate
news now g7 leaders say they'll work to
establish a climate club by the end of
this year a communique issued after
today's summit says it will aim to
advance ambitious and transparent
climate mitigation policies and reduce
intense emissions from participating
countries france's president macron also
told the summit in germany that major
world relations must continue with
climate and environmental goals despite
current pressures on energy markets
the united nations secretary-general
antonio guterres says the world is
facing an ocean emergency as thousands
of activists scientists and leaders
gather at the un ocean conference in the
portuguese capital lisbon they're
calling for measures to strengthen
protection of the seas
sadly
we have taken the ocean for granted
and today we face what i would call an
ocean emergency
we must turn the tide
global heating
is pushing ocean temperatures to record
levels
creating fiercer and more frequent storm
emergency services and charities are
working to rescue people in turkey after
flooding left many stranded heavy rain
in the northwest of the country has
caused rivers to overflow and bridges to
collapse the extreme weather comes less
than a week after turkey battled
wildfires in the southwest of the
country near the popular holiday resort
of marmarus
the famous notre dame cathedral in paris
will be redesigned to help mitigate the
effects of climate change the tourist
attraction is being rebuilt following a
fire in 2019. new plans involve planting
over 30 percent more vegetation and
installing a new cooling system a 5
millimeter layer of water will stream in
front of the cathedral during heat waves
aimed at reducing temperatures by
several degrees
now wimbledon is back this week and for
the first time in three years the game
sets and matches being played in front
of capacity crowds that's great for the
sporting atmosphere though potentially
not so good for the environment but the
all england lawn tennis club which is a
signatory to the un sport for climate
action framework is aiming to make these
championships the most sustainable yet
our sports presenter jackie bell trout
spoke to the club's sustainability
manager hatty park about the changes
well there are a lot of things different
at wimbledon this year and
most noticeably that strawberries and
cream are now served in a cardboard box
they still cost 2 pound 50 which is
pretty good value but they come in a
beautiful sort of recycled cardboard box
and the person behind that decision is
hatty park who's a sustainability um
chief in charge
of sorting all those things out and and
hattie um
what was behind all the decisions that
you've made for this year well it was
all part of our overall aim to be
environment positive so looking at
actions we can take to address climate
change resource depletion support nature
and we also know
that during the championships we have an
amazing opportunity to really engage
with everyone that comes here so we want
people to be part of it as well so you
know the packaging that the strawberries
come in is is part of that and thinking
about other ways that we can involve
everyone whether they're watching at
home or coming to the championships in
being part of this environment positive
journey that's so important yeah well
it's much more obvious this year because
as well as that you know you used to get
pims in a sort of throwaway plastic cup
now you've got to buy your plastic cup
and if you want your money back you've
got to bring the cup back don't you
exactly well that's really important to
promote a culture of reuse rather than
single use and throw away so that's what
we're aiming to do
you know we hope guests have a brilliant
day out we would like them to return the
cups to us they're taken away washed and
then come back so they can be used again
and again year after year or you can put
them in a box into the charity box and
then that pound goes to charity which is
a great idea and there's also um a
beautiful i haven't seen it yet but it's
going to be a beautiful wall of flowers
or plants tell me about that there's a
wall you know we present tennis in an
english garden there's an awful lot of
gorgeous planting around on the side of
number one court there's a living wall
which uh is an amazing backdrop for
people watching tennis on the hill but
it was deliberately planted with
flowering plants to encourage
pollinators
and you also which i find fascinating
collected all the strings from the
racket because the players go through a
lot of rackets during wimbledon the
strings break collected all of the old
strings cut off the rackets and did what
well we yeah we collected them last year
we've sent them away they've been ground
up mixed with other waste plastic and
they've come back in the form of
countertops on some ticket resolution
kiosks so they're back in the grounds
being useful i think that's the main
thing is that you know we wanted to get
something useful from those strings and
we collect them again this year so are
you going to go around now and just make
sure that everybody is doing what they
should be doing with their plastic cups
and with their cardboard strawberry
boxes yes i am i'm the i'm think i'm the
bin police i you know i try to think
strategically and then during the
championships i'm looking in the bins
hattie park bin police thank you very
much have a wonderful championship yeah
lots of changes around here but you know
changes for the better
and just before we leave you we want to
know your climate questions anything
that's ever mystified you or whatever
you want to get to the bottom of it's
all for a brand new weekend climate show
hosted by the environmental broadcaster
and author tom heap it starts this
saturday the 2nd of july and if you scan
the qr code on your screen right now you
can send us the questions that you want
to see answered on the show
that is all from us for now thanks so
much for watching